ce toutes les femmes sont belles prêt
bientôt zizi c'est par une phrase voilà
chacun la phrase qui résume votre vie
philosophiquement chacun des
chroniqueurs la phrase la praille
philosophie qui pourrait résumer votre
vie caroline alors elle est longue
ah oui c'est moi jamais
[Musique]
très angoissé qui réfléchit à côté qui
va dire et c'est ça c'est ça lui juste
après et là le mec je vois le vide dans
ses yeux bertrand est né comme ça plutôt
transparent mais ça ne vous inquiétez
pas ce sera vous un oui alors moi la
phrase qui résume à vis et impose ton
bonheur certes à chance va vers ton
risque à te regarder ils s'habitueront
tatouages
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rien compris mais c'est par ces
paroles et c'est sam char rue des
charmes sur rhône est chargé au monsieur
rené char c'est rené char la peur
n'évite pas le danger
non c'est vrai ouais mais la peur
[Musique]
quelle est la phrase qui résume votre
ville un tiens vaut mieux que deux tu
l'auras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
euh non c'est toutes les femmes sont
belles très bien ton si c'est vrai c'est
un mélange de franck mickaël et francky
bassin ces fraudes merci en tout cas en
philosophie vous aider à avoir eu cinq
méritait pas mieux je rappelle que vous
êtes le patron de télé 7 jours quelle
est la phrase qui peut drame de notre
époque c'est que la bêtise pense c'est
une phrase de jean cocteau que je trouve
assez juste pour aujourd'hui sont
cocteau jean joseph koto non je n'y
comprends rien alors et blagues
telle est la phrase qui peut résumer
voilà votre vie la phrase philosophique
seul l'amour d'une femme nous donne la
force d'être heureux non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors elle est très très courte un jour
ça sera pire vous avez le don de mac
l'ambiance est bien qu'elle me plaît
mais un jour français un jour ce sera
pire bamert silva oui on sait avec vous
c'est ça c'est telle est la phrase voilà
qui qui qui voilà qui vous représente
vous quand on ne sait pas où on va
vaut mieux y aller plus vite possible ah
ouais moi j'ai aussi quand on ne sait
pas où on va il vaut mieux acheter le
tomtom
[Applaudissements]
alors il n'aura quelle est la phrase
bouki kim en avant guingamp
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la glace que jean michel maire
c'est droite au but pas toujours
alors au nom d'une vraie phrase wii play
de coeur n'est pas mortelle sinon je
serais morte depuis le whip l'est de
coeur n'est pas mortelle sharks compris
j'aime beaucoup merci hainaut rab
[Musique]